what's up everybody it's your boy TR
here and we back with another video with
another Banger how everybody doing hope
everybody having a great
day yeah wait for the chat to load in
just a little bit before we start
everything where's the onesie no onesie
today man no onesie
today I
on
no no one
today
next week next week next
week all right yes as y'all know your
boy was back this week I was most
definitely Rusty but it's all good
sometimes you need games like that to
get
humble get refocused and that's exactly
what I needed so me and the team going
to go back to work go back to the
drawing board and come out and try
started go undefeated these last couple
games so we going to get we get back
right I mean we did the best we could do
you know I was still Rusty still getting
back into the groove of things but we
gonna fix it we gonna get it right ain't
nothing but a little little adversity
that's all it is all right y know he
went down y'all know he went down in the
game had coach Prime he didn't hold back
and yeah
so we
got you're not going to be taken care of
you're not going to be looked after
you're not going to have the luxuries of
all this and you going to have to go out
there and get it on your own and work
your butt off because ain't nobody going
to give you nothing I don't understand I
don't think you understand what this
world is consist
of what we just did today was
pathetic all the love that you receive
all the love we receive oh you getting
ready to see that flip and don't get
beside yourself on social media and
start responding to the foolishness
because they
right they
right and we practicing
tomorrow God
bless have a wonderful night I'm doing
good yeah that practice the next day was
crazy
though boy we had we only got a couple
hours to sleep for real woke up time to
go back to practice but that's what we
needed though had to get us back on the
right track and nobody pay attention to
the media anyways we let people talk
when we lose or when we win it doesn't
bother us it doesn't get to us so I just
let them talk I really don't
care I know I gotta go get back in and
go to work that's
it oh yeah looking at it positives from
the game yeah I got my first touchdown
yeah first
touchdown I mean at
Colorado
yeah you know first touchdown man it
felt great but we still end up Lo we a
end up winning so was great in the
moment but after that had a shallow
route did my route and
you know and then anything I could do to
get in the end zone that's what I had to
do and that's when I spent move game you
know the K SC me and Coach Prim
embracing on my way back to the S line
what did he say in that moment he didn't
say nothing he just said I love
you actually no he didn't he said uh you
know you got a penalty right I said oh
my bad
coach that's what I was after the
touchdown you see you know you got a
penalty
right it's like on my back but yeah you
know we got to continue work can't get
penalties like that but yeah my boy
Xavier you know you know 10 did his
thing like always three
touchdowns you know T gonna do his job
got him three touchdowns in
man listen right here I'm like oh my God
he is I put my hands up before he even
caught the ball soon as the ball went
there I put my hands
up yeah I was crazy
touchdown second was definitely a crazy
touchdown he just left
him D was nowhere to be found this play
we just worked on
this we worked on this play a lot in
practice and it ended up working in the
game it was just a walk in touchdown it
was
crazy everything happened that way was
supposed to happen everybody block who
they were supposed to block and what we
did it worked and that's what
happened yeah man do what I had to do Z
did what he had to do we just came up
short we did we got uh to
relax and yeah I took a freaking hit on
this touchdown right
here I had I know I was getting hit try
to ball up and turn away but it's too
late took a hit knock the wind out of me
hit me right my ribs they kind of pick
me up nah could fit me I had to I had to
walk over under my own power you know
coach Prime you know if you can walk you
ain't hurt so get off the field so
that's what I did but that hit hurt but
I know I had had to catch the ball no
matter what nobody care how hard I got
hit long as I C the ball that's all that
matter but I took a
shot that shot right there hurt worse
than my freaking cheap
shot
yeah that one hurt but you
know get up and play nobody care coach
prom ask asked the uh tough questions
was asked the tough questions about
loving the game and pro postr post game
uh press conference
what I just said in locker room to the
team is they got to makeup in their mind
are they in love with this game or they
in like with
it cuz when you love something you give
to it
unconditionally you give everything you
got without a shadow of a doubt I am
truly 100% in love with this
thing and I just want people to match me
just match my passion match
my match my heart match my love match my
consistency just match my mannerism just
match every DN thing I give to this game
yeah man stuff like that make you get a
second guess and do you love this game
or you just like it you just like to
play it because it's fun and I get what
he say right there man you gotta love
this game to go out there and put your
body on the line every day every time
gotta be willing to go out there and
dominate man but hey I love the game I
go down D every chance I get doesn't
matter if I'm Rusty ready to go still
going through stuff body still aching
I'm going out there to play give my best
and that's me I don't know about the
rest of the team I know a lot of players
on the team love the game but we got to
show more y'all know we got another
Monday night game who y'all got who
y'all put your money on oh the
Chargers Cowboys oh crap
we got man a lot of people say charges
by 30 that's crazy all
right it have been a week of upsets
49ers lost to the Browns that was crazy
Eagles lost to uh Eagles lost to the
Jets that was
crazy Jets lost a have neither one of
they
corners and the Eagles lost
so you know Miami Dolphins still did
thing Dak is washed come on bro leave
Dak alone man a nothing wrong with that
he go damn perform why he supposed to
what position am I going to play in the
NFL whichever one they pick me up for
man see they going to go off I hope he
do yes sir I'll make sure I keep gring
man all right now it's time for
overreaction not
overreaction let's get right into it
p with the address announcer St playing
while Stanford is form ready to snap the
ball any more playing of music and sound
effects will result in an unsort conduct
foul against col it's third
down I guess not not over reaction man
you can't be playing music while the
team's going I would want that to happen
to us I don't like that that's not good
can't be playing music while the
opposite team going no matter if you at
home or away that's just messed up
trying to knock them off focus they
already got a lot to think about it the
crowd already loud on I wouldn't want
that to happen to us so yeah not real
reaction you heard what he said stop
playing this is a weak coach promise
press this is a weak coach promise
press had a remarkable thanks to their
coach two sport Legend Dion Sanders here
to comment is Dion
Sanders Su what's up man like that black
dad
joke Crown time in the house you know
what I'm saying we just keep winning man
every game every minute we winning at
life yeah yeah well you're also four and
three so uh so you have lost a
few look at me man
what about me makes you think that I
care about what you think about me huh
you don't understand that my team has it
all maning yeah skipped this
offive yeah not overreaction that was
weak that was most definitely
weak losing your tooth after the catch
is
crazy that's that a
overreaction
oh how you losing is to
[Music]
though I know I seen that but how he
just lose his to his to just he just
spit his Toth up like a
dog what's going
on what the heck yeah I would have been
stuck I like bro what's going on
here yeah that's not overreaction that
is
crazy no better way than win then on the
Hail Mary it is a better way to
win don't get to the ha Mary
part yeah ha Mary is crazy oh I did see
this yeah that was
crazy it's now uh it's not
overreaction I mean actually it is
overreaction cuz it's a better way to
win don't get into the hair
Mary but that's a great catch though
that's definitely a great
catch that's some good luck right
there this ain't boxing are we talking
about the Logan Paul yeah I knew this is
coming yeah that's definitely not boxing
buddy not over reaction Lan Paul did
what he supposed to do though you see
how he's not trying to excal it trying
to back up just got to his Corner make
sure you know he didn't do nothing he
wasn't supposed to do just get out the
way
G his composion even though the dude was
still coming after him hey man that's
not a reaction that's definitely not
boxing I don't know what he was doing
guess he was just totally
losing your dog Pi up spits up teeth oh
no he got loose teeth right now though
CU you know I got him when he was a baby
he a spit it up
though Michael P had his house in moment
yes sir he definitely did he had a great
game that's definitely not an
overreaction he had a great game G
receivers was great chanes put a ball in
the right spot kept the ball
safe when it was they ball was their
ball and they did what they had to do
with the ball and yeah Michael Penn
definitely had his hman moment that game
that was
good you Michael Penn doing his
thing big man put put the clamps on him
I see
this oh reaction man big man ain't CL
nothing he ain't CL
nothing man just dropped the
ball this can't be real what we talking
about what we
got ain't no way
Bo there's no way
Bo not over reaction that can't be real
how is that even possible bro he's just
recording and
just this is a decent pull let me
see
oh Hecks no
boy yeah ain't no way I'm going to mess
with that shark go ahead you take it the
whole thing go
byebye taking the S doing doing the back
flip as well first person footage yes
sir definitely is it's t Hill man that's
definitely wow that's not over reaction
though that's
wow
hey that's
crazy I bet he got f for that too I know
he got f for it the NFL you know they
they're not F to let him do that because
if other people start doing it they feel
like it's not good this what national
football leaders for but they don't care
about that
stuff I don't let people have too much
fun this isn't
human
oh yeah buddy I don't know what you have
done right there it's like he don't even
jump like he hit the ground before he
the ball is even in the hoop like d why
the ball is going in the hoop he's on
the
ground that's not human bro not
overreaction for
real no fun Le yeah a lot of people were
saying that I don't know man it's kind
of messed up
bro can't have fun think Target kills
the toughest cover the toughest to cover
in the NFL yes bro he's super fast
bro you just got to run literally that's
all he do so all he had to do is run he
quick too though so don't get him don't
get it messed up now he's fast but he's
also
quick tra can we see your favorite
onesie in the collection uh I don't have
a favorite one man I got a lot of ones
in the collection though
all right man let's build a perfect Ro
receiver
hands come on chat let's build a uh
perfect roer who got the best hands in
the league right now who should we
put
di obj CP George pickings dicks which
one are we gonna
pick all right I feel like we should uh
pick the
no I would say Devonte Adams
but Jamar
Chase pick the
dehw hey I see Justin Jefferson Grant
Wilson all right we're gonna go with uh
Justin Jefferson for H that's what y'all
want ah yeah Devonte uh Devonte Adams
Devonte Adams Devonte Adams for
hands we got Devonte Adams for hands
damn but Devonte Adams got them routes
too
though all right Devonte Adams for hands
speed we GNA go with uh who we go with
speed T Hill or jayen W them boys are
fast
man tar for Speed all right tar for
Speed Target kill for Speed route
running stuff unde got some clean route
running M Adam got some clean route
running
too what y'all
thinking Mike
Evans Devonte is Route running Devonte
is Route running but he got good hands
too hey we going digs we going we going
digs
man Stu on digs for money man blocking
definitely going DK matf no Brandon auk
Brandon auk Brandon auk actually br
like uh
blur who we had type of stuff man yeah
Jamar Chase he he is gonna blur some 90%
of the
time AJ Brown do to though see this
perfect receiver got hands like mon app
speed like Tek how I mean Tek Hill uh
route running like Stu on digs blocking
like like BR iuk blur like pickings yeah
George pickings for blur and drip uh we
going we going what's the name uh
D going Debo s for Dr
man
Deo
Deo AJ Brown do be having drip too but
Debo be putting that stuff
on I like that I like that one sleeve I
also like Stefan digs one leave but yeah
I could have added myself in this list
or no I had to make my my own perfect uh
receiver H NFL players all right yeah I
couldn't add I couldn't add myself y'all
it was uh only NFL receivers next up we
got a
blur let's get into
it Florida State receiver Keon Coleman
blur
Nation yeah that one snack is crazy bro
that's a blur blur on this head
I got blur too y'all we ain't gonna
leave that out we should have put that
up
here that's blur for
Shi blur head top yep that's a blur
that's just that's good defense though
if he look back early enough he he's
perfect perfect
time uh let's go Indiana receiver yeah
it's not a blur but we can call it a
blur on his
head he landed on his head for real
though I know that had to hurt bro he be
coming down so fast bro actually it
probably didn't hurt that bad actually
we on the football field none of that
stuff be hurting for
real
blue one hand grab that's a great catch
there's nothing you can do about that
that's good coverage it's a great
catch d That's crazy
man yeah it's a great catch man I don't
know you can't there nothing else you
can do I seen this gr wison it's
crazy got both feet now
he had a good game too that's definitely
he had a great game that's a hell of a
catch I don't know how he CAU that but
he caught it well actually I do know how
he caught it just like
that both feet down B bom hold on bom
yep great catch Grant what's in all
right man before we get out of here you
know we got a B week got to sit on that
loss man that crazy loss for this this
week don't feel good but we got ball
week this
week uh we know going into these
upcoming games man it's either
win or win it's nothing else for real
you just we just got to go out there win
we can't it's already half season Mark
man we got five more guaranteed games
what it's like 20 more practices we got
to go out and dominate football season
came by so fast I mean came by so slow
but when it got here it's moving fast so
we gotta go there dominate come out fast
try to be the best best
team uh be a second half team for this
year I mean for this second half of the
year go out and dominate like we didn't
do in the uh first half just go out then
prepare right dominate be the best
team and
win what I'll be doing since I was hurt
the last three weeks uh I'm about to get
back in that lab going to lift weights
every
day train every day and just get ready
for the next game no B week for me I'm
staying here going up train with uh
coaches and stuff just get get my work
in it's time to get my hours back up
lock back in football no more playing
around going to workout every day at the
facility so yeah that's my main thing
and that's what I'm going to do go back
and work out after school and just
continue to get better every day so I
could be the best teammate on the uh for
my team and that's it
we're gonna bounce back finish this
season out the right way not the wrong
way who are you most excited to go up
against in NFL DB or
receiver uh I don't know I feel like
stuff on D will be fun because it's like
a big brother it's like a big brother
man all the guys in the NFL right now
it's like big brothers to me so it' be
fun to go against them
guys uh DB same they like uncles you
know you know you just got to go out
there and play man I I I want to play
all them guys I mean I want to play the
best so that's what I'm looking forward
to
doing guess who's calling me
honcho you know he want to get on the
game right now but
yeah so we
doing get rest boss I already got my
rest man it's time to go out there and
just play time for me to go dominate go
back into uh get back into that
mode
no have you
know can't can't do nothing have just
time to go to work eat gain some weight
G put on a couple more pounds over this
week and just be ready to go out and
dominate for the second half like I said
for the season so it's your host Travis
hun 12 talks love y'all be safe over
this week see y'all next Monday with
some upcoming
games continue to be blessed we're going
to watch the Chargers and the Cowboys
tonight and we're GNA come back with the
winners next Monday peace
[Music]
out